- Hi, everyone.
My name is Priya Natarajan
and I'm the current director
of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities at Yale.
I welcome you all warmly to
the final spring semester event
this afternoon.
We have a lot of exciting new
events planned for this fall,
including a talk and musical performance
by the internationally acclaimed
jazz composer, performer,
and former Yale College
physics undergraduate alum,
as it turns out, Vijay Iyer.
I would also like to
remind you to contribute
to our ongoing Learning by Doing Project
and submit videos of
do-at-home science projects
to add to our bank.
Anyway, coming back to today,
we have an exciting talk
by one of our own
brilliant young scholars,
a Franke fellow, Dr. Ana Florence.
First, I would like to start
by recognizing our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke.
Their generosity is what makes
this flagship interdisciplinary
program at Yale possible.
I'm delighted that Mrs.
Franke has joined us today.
And I want to remind all
of you who are assembled
that we are recording this event,
and all participants will
therefore have their videos muted
for the duration of the talk,
and any questions that you might have
that arise during the talk
maybe submitted at any time
in the Q&A feature.
Nearly five years ago, when
I took over as the director
of the Franke Program, and
had a wonderful long coffee
with Rich Franke, one of
the first things I told him
that I wanted to do was
to expand the footprint
of the extremely successful
Franke Fellowship
and extend it to graduate students
and postdoctoral scholars at Yale.
He was incredibly enthusiastic and excited
at the possibility of
extending the support
for interdisciplinary
projects across the board
to many more Yalies.
I am utterly delighted to introduce
one of our recent
postdoctoral Franke fellows,
Dr. Ana Florence, as our speaker today.
The title of her talk
is Social and Structural
Contours of Marginalization
in the Context of COVID-19.
So Ana is amongst our
cohort of graduate student
and postdoctoral scholars
who get Franke Fellowship support money
to seed ambitious, bold ideas
that cross disciplinary boundaries
during their time at Yale.
Dr. Ana Florence, who is a
recent postdoctoral fellow
from the Franke Program,
is a clinical psychologist
who is originally from
Brazil, with experience
in the institutionalization
and implementation
of public community-based
mental health services.
Her scholarship focuses on
the open dialogue approach
and other dialogic practices
for people experiencing psychosis.
And she has worked on
human rights and the role
of lived experience in
transforming systems practices
and conceptions of mental health.
She has recently joined
Columbia University
as a postdoctoral fellow and
also works with the OnTrackNY,
engaging youth and young adults
in research and quality improvement
to support a learning healthcare
system in New York City.
For her Franke project, and
this is what really attracted us
to her work and alerted us
to the talent that she brings
to this wonderful project,
she aimed to address the
current understanding
of the mental health impacts
of COVID-19 pandemic.
It was an extremely
timely and urgent project.
This unprecedented public health crisis,
she claimed in her proposal,
begs a comprehensive understanding
of the social, economic, psychological,
and political underpinnings of suffering.
Through a strong multidisciplinary focus,
she suggested that she would look
at ways to expand the ways
in which mental health impact
of COVID-19 is conceptualized,
inviting the voices of those
who have gone through mental
health challenges in the past,
and have accrued valuable wisdom
in their recovery journey to the fore.
She offered to hold a
series of consensus groups
guided by her previous
research on this topic
to develop this new conceptual framework.
Broadening our
understanding of this crisis
to include the social dimension
of experiences of suffering
can inform public policy
and future research
to better respond collectively
to this global emergency.
So I was just reading
out of her wonderful,
super compelling proposal that
we got a couple of years ago,
and I'm delighted to tell you
that Ana will be talking to us today
about this Wisdom Project,
this project, which was born in the wake
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
And what she has done and
will be talking to us today
is to reacquaint us
with a group of persons
with lived experience with
mental health problems,
and for whom she has produced
a series of webinars,
with whom, for whom she has
produced a series of webinars,
podcasts, and conducted research
on how we can collectively make sense
of these hugely disruptive phenomenon.
This pandemic, far from
being a great equalizer,
which is what we all
originally thought, right,
has brought to fore the issues
that are at the very core of
our very inequitable societies
that we can no longer ignore,
systemic racism, oppression,
poverty, and health inequities,
and access to healthcare inequities.
Her talk today will focus on a series
of regional conversations
that invited the voices
and experiences of those
who have endured firsthand
what it's like to survive
precarious livelihoods,
racism, oppression, marginalization,
stigma, and other unfreedoms.
We are excited and utterly delighted
to have you speak to us today, Ana.
And we really look forward to hearing more
about this wonderful Franke project.
Ana, take it away.
- Thank you so much, Priya.
That was a wonderful introduction.
I'm just gonna start sharing my screen
and we'll ask someone to confirm
if you can see my slides.
- [Woman] Looks great.
- Perfect, thank you so much.
So I would first like to
start by also thanking
the Franke Program for
the support of this work.
I don't think this work could
ever have happened without it.
And as Priya was mentioning,
it aligns so well
with the mission of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities at Yale,
and I think one of the
pieces that really fit well
with the work that I was
already previously doing
is the interdisciplinary piece.
And so, I really wanna start by saying
that I didn't do this work alone,
and by centering my
colleagues and everyone
that was involved through these past,
I'd say two years this
research has been happening.
And I really wanted to also
say that we were a team
and a collective of
scholars and activists,
and we came from various
different backgrounds,
from psychologists, to
sociologists, to historians.
And we came from different countries.
Folks who participated were
based in Brazil, and Canada,
and here in the United States.
And one important feature
of this entire project
that I would like to
center is that a number
of participants of the core team
were people who had firsthand experience
of mental health challenges, or madness,
or extreme states, or however
people want to conceptualize
and identify as.
And I think that this was a core
and very important feature of this group.
And also, the work that we
did in the various engagements
attempted to be as
participatory as we could.
And I think we can claim here and say that
our work was actually led by people
who had firsthand or direct experience
with the mental health system.
So with that, I'd like to start by saying
a little bit about what
this Wisdom Project was
and how it emerged.
So initially, once the pandemic started,
we were all doing research.
And I bet that people on this call
were also doing research
that seemed quite relevant
at the moment.
And then with this huge
disruption that happened,
we felt like, at least in our group,
that we had to shift priorities
and maybe start doing some research,
or maybe just even getting together,
I think, was the initial initial thought,
around understanding
what the impact would be
for people with mental health challenges
or people who were in
the mental health system.
Two narratives emerged very
early on in the pandemic
about mental health.
And part of this work
was to actually challenge
some of these conceptualizations
that emerged very early on.
One of them is that the COVID-19 pandemic
would bring a tsunami of mental illness.
This was something that the
media was talking about,
but it was something
that also made its way
into academic literature and research.
And it looked pretty early
on that conceptualizations
of how people would respond
to a global emergence
of an unknown virus
that was killing people
by the thousands daily,
that that would be framed
as a mental challenge
or a mental illness.
And that really kind
of got our antennas up
because there is a history in our field
of centering attention to the individual
rather than understanding
the social determinants
of why human suffering happens
in certain circumstances
and why it manifests the way it does.
So this was kind of one
initial thing that we felt,
or our group felt like we
needed the challenge early on.
And then the other response
to a tsunami of mental illness
is to ramp up services.
So the idea that more
people would become ill
and more people would need services
would prompt a response in
increasing access to service,
increasing services offered.
And we also wanted to challenge that
and include
a view more grounded and rooted
in social determinants of health
rather than individual pathology,
if I can put it that way.
And that's not to say that
there isn't suffering,
but it's really, how do
we understand suffering
in such an extreme context,
and how do we draw the line
of what suffering is
appropriate, acceptable, normal,
and what suffering warrants
treatments, services, diagnoses.
So really, what the
pandemic kind of re-centered
are some questions that
are part of psychiatry
and are part of the
so-called side disciplines,
since their emergence as disciplines.
And so, they're not really new problems,
but they were just kind
of centered very suddenly
once the world response
to the pandemic started
being conceptualized
as mental illness.
And another element that pretty early on
also appeared in the narrative
is this idea of crisis as opportunity.
And for some curious reason,
for something different entirely,
I was rereading Susan Sontag's,
one of the books that she wrote
that's called "Illness as Metaphor."
The book actually comes with two,
the book that I got is two books of hers.
And one is "Illness as Metaphor"
and then the other is
"AIDS and Its Metaphors."
And that's a book she wrote
about the AIDS epidemic.
And I was just surprised to see
a type of prophetic
kind of content in this book.
And as I read it, I felt like
I could just switch words
and kind of see a complete repetition
of something that had happened in the past
with the AIDS epidemic,
including the inequities and inequalities
that were seen in the day,
back with the AIDS epidemic,
but also some of the
metaphors that it instilled.
And it was just very interesting to,
also, she quotes the, at the time,
the head of the WHO
saying things very similar
to what we were hearing the
current head of the WHO say.
So it was quite interesting
to see how history repeats itself
and how it's not always that we learned
something from history.
So in terms of the crisis as opportunity,
that's an interesting idea,
but we wanted to challenge
in the sense that,
opportunity for whom, and
who takes this opportunity?
And how is crisis being conceptualized?
I think all of this, for instance,
for the global north,
this looked a certain way
with the pandemic, with the vaccines,
and with the ability to provide services.
But then in the global south,
it certainly looked very different.
And for instance, one of our colleagues
who was based in Brazil was
doing some research around
how COVID was being experienced
in the favelas of Brazil.
And then for the people
that they were interviewing,
that wasn't a crisis at all,
it was just another thing.
Crisis were related to
hunger, to not having food,
to not having a roof over your head,
and to problems of basic subsistence
that were really much more important
than another virus.
And so, this idea of crisis is an idea
that has a place
and that has a context to exist.
And also, this idea of opportunity,
opportunity for whom and
what type of opportunity?
And also, did we take this opportunity,
something that was on our mind.
So today, I'll talk
about how we went about
addressing these issues.
How do we engage and understand this?
The way we did it is just
by going to the source.
I think that we, early
on, came up with a number
of strategies to engage with people
in multiple different ways,
both through ways that would
be considered research,
but also in other ways.
We did a number of webinars and podcasts
that I'll talk about,
we wrote a commentary and published it,
we did listening sessions.
So it was really a mix of
a lot of different ways
to engage with people.
And we ended up, I think,
engaging with many more
than we would've expected
at the beginning.
So what I'll do today in my
talk is talk a little bit
about those listening sessions,
what we learned there
and how that informed
the following stages of this project,
what we published,
the podcast series that we did,
the webinars, and
finally the focus groups,
and those were the regional conversations
that were national in kind of geography,
and kind of finishing up
with some final thoughts
that I hope won't be too
disappointing. (laughs)
And every time I see researchers talking,
I hear, you know, I'm good
at asking more questions
and never answering anything.
And I feel like I might be
blamed for the same problem,
but I'll do my best to keep us all engaged
in this conversation.
I should also add that there is a reason
why we wanted to discuss marginalization,
and mental health, and oppression.
So those issues, I mean,
as Priya was saying
at the beginning, if folks thought,
and I feel like I was naive enough
to think that this might
be the great equalizer
and that it would affect everyone.
And so, maybe this
would bring us together.
I guess, really, early days, I was trying
to remain optimistic, but
then very, very early on,
we saw incredible disparities,
and that the pandemic
was really affecting people
in very, very different ways.
And those different ways are not random.
Those different ways are
related to the inequities
and the structural issues
that have been part of society
for a long, long time,
and have gone unaddressed,
and then came squarely to the
fore as the pandemic emerged.
And I'll just give a
brief, I don't wanna draw
too many statistics for
this talk as my research
is mostly qualitative,
and I like to be very close
to what people tell us,
and you'll see that there
will be a lot of quotes
as we move along.
But I'll just say that
for a person diagnosed
with a mental disorder,
the mortality of COVID was much higher
than persons without a diagnosis.
And within this group of people
with the psychiatric diagnosis,
people diagnosed with schizophrenia
had an even higher mortality rate.
And that is considered a
serious mental illness.
And then I'll also add that when compared
to White Americans and adjusted for age,
African Americans are
3.6 times more likely.
Native Americans are
3.4 times more likely.
And Latinx are 3.2 times more
likely to die from COVID-19.
So that really also
informed a lot of our work.
And so, those were very sobering things
that we learned early on.
I wanna say that, I wish it surprised me,
but once we started learning
and once the research started coming out,
I have to say that anyone
that's in this area
knows that these inequities are
in place and it was expected
that they would affect people differently.
So I wanted to start by presenting
the listening sessions that we had.
So listening sessions are just a way
of convening people in a
slightly informal forum
without much of an agenda.
This was so early, this was April, 2021.
So this was very early on in the pandemic.
And what we really wanted
to do was to understand
whether people had had
a previous experience
with the mental health system,
whether it be being hospitalized
because of a mental health issue,
or having had a diagnosis
of a mental disorder,
how people were understanding the pandemic
and how were they, and this has a history,
it comes from an idea that also
was a narrative that early on emerges,
that people who have a previous diagnosis
of mental health challenges
would likely be more affected
or affected in a worse way,
or have poor outcomes than
people without a diagnosis.
So we just wanted to understand
a little bit how people were dealing
with having to isolate, and
having to shelter in place,
and just kind of,
it was a very informal
set of conversations
to lay the groundwork for the
other engagements that we did.
And so, a couple of themes
that I thought would be
interesting to share with you
is that, first of all,
so many experts emerged
as the pandemic hit.
And one of the questions that we heard
in our listening sessions
were, "Who are the experts?"
So all this stuff about
surviving a pandemic,
and that's a direct
quote of a participant,
expert advice, as if anybody
alive has experienced
a pandemic before and is an expert in it.
So I think that was very interesting
because psychologists, psychiatrist,
and mental health professionals
were being called to
talk about the pandemic
and kind of the mental
health impact of it.
And it was just very interesting
because this is one instance
where we are all going
through it together.
And I can't really say as a
clinical psychologist myself
that I have more experience than someone
that I'm seeing as a client
or a patient, than them.
And so, in that sense, it kind
of levels the power dynamics
between professionals
and non-professionals.
So that was something
that came up early on.
And we also hoped that that would allow us
to think more critically
about these power imbalances
that are part of
therapeutic relationships,
and that the expert knows
more about you than yourself
and kind of flip that on
its head and think that,
"Well, maybe the expert
on my own life is me
and not the person that I'm
seeing as a professional."
And that's something that's part
of kind of the critical work in this area,
the area of mental health.
So there was some hope
that maybe we could talk
more about these issues
now that everyone would be going
through this pandemic together
and kind of experiencing
it at the same time,
and it'd be very hard
to claim being an expert
anymore than any other person.
So that was an interesting
thing we learned there.
And then also, some knowledge and wisdom
from direct experience with mental health,
with hospitalizations and with,
you know, maybe even
coercive mental health
kind of treatments.
And then I think one thing
we heard a number of times
is that people have lived experience,
have lived experience in trauma,
but they also have lived
experience in recovery.
And so, in some ways, in
these listening sessions,
we heard a lot that some of us that,
you know, a previous history,
with a mental health challenge,
could be seen as putting people
in a more vulnerable position,
was actually being conceptualized
by the people that we were listening to
by actually having had some experience
that is useful for this context,
and being sometimes more
prepared than their counterparts
who never had any lived
experience with trauma,
or direct experience with trauma,
or a psychiatric diagnosis.
So that was an interesting
take on things as well.
Maybe what was thought as a vulnerability
is actually kind of an asset.
Something else that we heard
that was interesting and
not surprising to me,
but it might be surprising to some,
is a lot of people said,
"Well, welcome to my life."
Some people have to self isolate anyway
because of chronic illness
or other conditions
that make it harder for them to get out.
And they're like,
"Welcome to my experiences
on a regular basis."
And we heard different things as well.
So we heard from people
who were hospitalized multiple times,
for instance, that they
were told what to do before.
This is not the first time
that they're being told
that they can't leave the
room, that they can't leave,
or that they can't do something
that they wanted to do.
And so, not to romanticize
those experiences
or say that it's good
to go through trauma,
'cause that protects you
from even more traumatic
experiences in the future,
but just to say that
some of the assumptions
about fragility and about vulnerability,
related to how people go
through these experiences,
may not map out to their real experiences.
And one huge concern that
came up time and time again
was, I think, kind of the
driver of this whole project,
is I wonder how we can
counter that narrative
and not have this be an opportunity
to funnel more people into
the mental health system.
I worry that that's where we'll go
instead of social change and
addressing disparities issues.
And I think this direct quote
from one of our participants
really was kind of decisive
for taking the route that we did.
And so, those listening sessions
really shaped all the other engagements
that we planned for this project,
beyond the research piece.
But you'll see that we also had,
the webinars and the podcasts
were more related to engaging with people
rather than to extract data.
And then I'll show us a quote
that really was one of the
most striking for me early on
and made me, it was really provocative.
So someone in our listening session said,
"When I went psychotic,
people talked about me
personally breaking from reality.
But it seems like reality
is breaking from all of us.
So what do you call that?"
And that was a very, to
me, important provocation
in terms of how we
conceptualize mental illness,
mental health challenges, mental problems,
however you wanna call it.
What happens when something so disruptive
happens in reality,
in shared and consensus
reality, what do we call it?
And then from those listening sessions,
we actually wrote a
commentary which we published.
And the commentary was coauthored
by a number of people
who are not academics,
who are people who have
had a previous diagnosis,
a mental health diagnosis,
or people who were activists.
So this is one example of
kind of how it's possible
to maybe bridge some of these gaps
between academia and activism,
or academia and kind of
regular life, I would say,
in that we really invited everyone
who participated in the listening
sessions to be co-authors.
And it was really written
by multiple hands.
And so, we published that early on.
"When reality breaks from us:
lived experience wisdom
in the COVID-19 era."
And we did outline some of those themes
and kind of thought about some
directions for the future.
And then the other piece that we did,
I mean, we just didn't
wanna do research only.
We wanted to take the
interdisciplinary aspect of things
to another level, in that we
not only wanted to do research
between different disciplines,
but we also wanted to
engage different media,
and engage people that are
sitting in different places,
including some policy makers.
And some of the names
that you'll see there
are policy makers and some people
who are working within the system,
and then a mix with people
who have lived experience
or direct experience.
And so, we did this podcast series
in which we just talked
rather quite informally
about the issues that were coming up.
So that was in partnership
with C4 Innovations
and the Mental Health
Technology Transfer Center
for the New England region.
And we covered a lot of topics,
from surviving the mental health system,
to alternative understandings
of human suffering,
to peer support work, to social
justice and racial equity.
And so, we kind of came up
with the themes together
based on what we were hearing
in our listening sessions,
but also what our core
team was kind of indicating
would be an interesting direction to go
and the types of resources
that we thought people might want
but might not have access to.
And then we also did this webinar series
that was also kind of, early on.
And we did three separate webinars
that was also in partnership
with the Mental Health
Technology Transfer Center.
And that reached a national audience
and folks from Canada as well.
We had a number of states
represented in these calls.
And they're available for anyone
who just wanna go into the website.
And so, we did one based
on that initial theme,
welcome to my world.
Then we did one on social
justice and COVID-19.
And we also did one on peer
support and essential workers.
I just wanna check how I'm doing on time.
Okay.
And now I just wanna transition
to kinda the more researchy
phase of this project.
It's just a mix of different
methods and different things.
And we really wanted to make sure
that we were kind of weaving in research,
and activism, and engaging
and connecting with people,
and not just doing research.
So sometimes, I look at this and I wonder,
is this a little slightly
disjointed methodology?
But in fact, it was really the result
of us trying to figure out
how to navigate the space
and how to kind of rapidly respond
to the needs that we were seeing
just in our daily lives.
It just felt like everyone
was going through everything
at the same time and you
don't have the luxury
of hindsight or of time.
So with that kind of preliminary work
and those engagements
that we had early on,
then we went ahead and had
a number of focus groups.
And that was a very long process
for our team to kind of develop
what we wanted to ask people,
but also how we wanted to capture
vulnerability, marginalization,
and the experiences that we
were looking to understand.
And so, we, through an iterative process
of going over the themes that we saw
in the listening sessions,
but also, being current
with the literature
that was coming out on this subject,
we developed some areas of focus
that we thought would be really important
to touch on.
And so, we ended up
landing on these themes.
And then when we recruited,
people were invited
to self-select to the group that they felt
was closer to their experience.
And so, for that, we had experiences
with mental health and substance
use during the pandemic.
And we did actually two focus groups
with that subject or that topic.
We had experiences of poverty,
and then people self-selected
to that group as well.
Experiences with invisibility
and virus exposure,
and that was related to essential workers,
people who were not able
to shelter in place,
such as bus drivers or
people in essential services,
like janitorial services in hospitals.
And there was a lot of attention
to how much healthcare professionals
were exposed to the virus,
but there was an entire
contingent of people
who were working daily,
never sheltered in place and made sure
that services continued,
and that we're not clapped to,
and applauded, and thanked by society,
and in fact, we're getting
sick, and we're dying,
and we're in this kind
of invisibility position.
And so, we wanted to make
sure that we talked to people
who had that experience.
And then experiences with
housing and food insecurity.
We also wanted to know
how people experienced
kind of the rapid
emergence of some benefits
that were maybe long due,
but suddenly, when the pandemic started,
there was the eviction moratorium,
there was a number of different benefits
that people could access,
there were hotel rooms
for people who were
experiencing homelessness.
And so, it just seemed
like a lot of things
that people were advocating for
for a very long time
suddenly became possible.
And we really wanted to understand
how people who have had these experiences
in the past were dealing with it now,
and the impact of these new programs
that emerged after COVID.
We also understood very clearly
that incarcerated populations
were being kind of left
behind in many ways
with COVID.
And so, we wanted to make sure
that we also centered those experiences.
And we also wanted to talk to activists
and understand what happened to activism.
And did everything shift focus
when the pandemic started?
Was activism galvanized
by this or did it die out?
So we were really interested
in kind of hearing more
about that as well.
So, as I mentioned, it was a joint process
of developing these themes
to make sure that we captured
a wide gamut of experiences
of vulnerability,
marginalization, and oppression
that people could be experiencing.
So the way we worked to disseminate this
and to recruit folks was we used a number
of activism-related listservs
and just our personal kind of connections,
but also, yeah, I mean,
just any type of listserv.
It was really, we cast a wide, wide net.
And we really ended up getting folks
from all over the country participating
in these conversations.
So we ended up, for this stage,
having 36 participants who
joined seven focus groups.
So that's just some of the characteristics
of people who participated.
The mean age was 48-years-old.
For those who did answer
the demographics questions,
we had 19 female, 3 male, and
1 fluid non-binary person.
Six participants identified
as Black or African American.
1 identified as biracial and 14 as White.
And then a number of
people didn't fill out
the demographics,
so we don't have very
complete date on that.
16 reported having one or
more psychiatric diagnoses
and 8 reported substance use challenge.
Nine reported having one
or more disabilities.
Eight of the participants reported
being on SSI or SSDI or are
receiving other benefits
to report a history of homelessness.
Five participants had a
history of incarceration
or of a family member who
had been incarcerated.
Most participants reported multiple
and intersecting vulnerabilities.
And six participants had COVID themselves.
And another three had close
family members who had COVID.
So the first thing that
was kind of surprising,
I guess it shouldn't be, but it was,
because a lot of the research
and a lot of the media narratives
sometimes makes us think
that things are linear
and kind of homogenous.
But in fact, when we
started talking to people,
a lot of people described
the whole experience
of the pandemic in a positive light,
and found silver linings
or found very positive
things that happened
as a result of the pandemic.
But most people certainly
described challenges,
and that's obviously also by virtue
of what we wanted to talk about.
But one of the positive things
that people talked about
was being able to reconnect with family
around the world via Zoom,
and so feeling more connected.
Some people really described it as,
"It was a nightmare.
I recycled to supplement my
food and my many other needs,
and I couldn't do it for the first month,
we were all locked down.
And then afterwards, still,
to this date, not safe.
I don't feel safe, safe doing anymore."
And then some people
described their experiences
just neutral.
So "I think it wasn't
that disruptive for me
simply because I'm older
and I'm more set in my ways.
I have the same routine
I've had for years.
Plus, I'm able to entertain
myself because I have a lot
of electronic entertainment in my home."
And so, we heard mixed things.
Like we kind of went in
maybe with our assumptions,
that it would be a really
challenging experience
for everyone, but yeah, we learned
that there was just
this wide heterogeneity
of how people experienced it.
But not just how they experienced,
but how they talked about it.
In terms of isolation and connectedness,
I feel like that was a
theme that came up a lot.
Most participants really
emphasized isolation,
loneliness, and lack of connection.
So one example here,
"I was so disconnected, so alone,
and in the psychotic state,
that I really needed people.
I was just too isolated."
So some people did describe that.
And then
what else here?
So "What we saw was that people
not only were using the
previous connected channels
through their local clubhouses,
but were interacting beyond the scope
of their small community."
So that's one example
of connectedness, right?
So this is in the context of having
like 12 step groups online,
and then some therapeutic
groups and meetings
that went beyond their communities,
and actually reached many more people
than they would've imagined.
In terms of the stimulus
checks and other benefits,
most participants who received them
found them to be very helpful.
And some even experienced
financial and housing stability
for the first time in very many years.
So a participant here, "I've
lived in a cycle of poverty
almost my entire life.
And basically, when I
was raising my daughter,
it was the only time I was really stable
as far as financially goes.
And then just recently, with
a stimulus and unemployment,
very helpful."
We also heard a lot, and I think that
that experience certainly transcends
any, I guess, any vulnerability
or marginalization,
but the time's feeling
very politically fraught,
and participants talked a
lot about polarized views
and difficulties navigating
very politically-charged conversations.
And then one example, I guess, is,
we can see here,
"I would love to get
another stimulus check,
but I don't think we deserve it.
I saw too many people using it
for reasons that they
shouldn't have used it for.
So I don't think we deserve
another stimulus check."
So some of this was in very
kind of charged context
and with very strong views.
And then others here,
"I've stopped talking
about COVID-19 to people
because it's become so
politicized in my family.
I'm not gonna get a lot into them."
And so, this feeling was really,
it came up a lot and
with very strong views
about various different issues.
In terms of activism in people
that have been activists before,
they had really described
this kind of an awareness
of the need to continue activism,
but also a sense of urgency
that may have not been there before.
And so, one example here,
"I'm not sure that I increased
my activism or decreased.
It definitely didn't
decrease during the pandemic,
but it definitely became a
bit more urgent, I would say."
And then another participant here,
"I figured out a way to
shake the foundation.
I got active.
It wasn't that I really
wanted to become active,
but I probably should have been
doing this a long time ago.
But it stood up my activism
of how I could change
the outcomes of someone
in certain circumstances
that I was witnessing."
So we did hear a lot of
that in the focus groups,
that people just felt activated.
And then in terms of poverty,
financial challenges
associated with the pandemic
and the benefits that people received,
those were discussed quite extensively.
And then I would just read
the participants' quotes.
"Financially, I work one full-time job
and two part-time jobs,
all at the same place.
I lost the two part-time jobs.
So it was a struggle to pay
my bills, but I'm making it.
It's hard and I still have
anxiety attack from it."
Someone else say, "Oh,
health wise, you know,
I'm not working anymore.
I went on SSDI my sister said,
you know, financially, I took a big hit."
Someone else said, "I've lost money.
There's monetary things thing
in terms of being affected.
I had just had surgery, but during COVID,
I've been a part-time musician.
I couldn't do any gigs so I lost money
that's a lot of money."
And then someone, "But then I was eligible
for the pandemic unemployment.
And that was really helpful.
I started building my credit,
returned to college to
study cybersecurity.
And that's good.
And paid off my driver's license fines,
was able to send my brother
who was incarcerated
some money, and was able to
get my daughter some money."
So really overwhelmingly
positive experiences
with receiving additional benefits.
And then in terms of injustices
that people talked about,
some people said, "I've spent a lot of it,
a lot of the pandemic being
very angry with a lot of people,
including government officials.
I'm trying to work my way through that
and in realizing that
some policy decisions
that they made that seemed
profoundly inequitable,
especially for people with
disabilities at the time."
And then just, "Everyone
should be treated equally
because we're all human beings.
Where you come from, if
you're Black or White,
rich or poor, you should
be treated with dignity
when you are sick."
And then we also had, you
know, racism was a topic
that came up in most of
the groups that we did,
and then in various different ways,
which shouldn't be surprising either.
So one quote here, "And here
is one way I think everyone
here has agreed that clearly,
we got a racist system here.
That's deadly.
We got that."
And then someone talking
about their own experience.
"It took me back to
when I was 11 years old,
when I was stopped by the police
and they frisked me and they checked me.
And they said I looked like someone
who had committed a crime.
At 11-years-old, I knew
that I could be vulnerable
for certain things.
COVID has let me know,
has let me also know
about the disparities in healthcare.
Poor people, Black
people, and brown people
have been such high numbers."
And then one, I was kind of divided
of whether I should
keep this quote or not,
but I decided to keep it here and read it.
I certainly had never, and
I've been in the United States
for three years now.
As Priya mentioned, I'm
originally from Brazil.
And I don't think I had ever encountered
something as direct as this before.
And that maybe, by virtue
of being an academic center,
but I should read this quote and say that,
you know, one of our
participants said very clearly,
"But I tell people I am racist.
And I will be racist till the day I die.
I grew up in a racist family.
Seeing a Black man walking down the street
and calling him up.
N word was nothing to me in St.
Paul, when I was growing up.
But to me, I can be friends with someone
who's Native American.
I can be friends with someone
who's African American.
But I don't like the organization.
I don't like Black Lives Matter.
I don't like the other stuff.
But I have friends who are
all different races and stuff.
So, yeah, it's kind of a
catch 22, if I can say that."
So it was really a very broad,
I guess this was one
participant out of the 36
that we interviewed.
And the majority of views aligned
with the views that you see
on the previous two quotes.
But that's just an example, I guess,
of how much work we still have to do
around racial equity,
about anti-racism work.
Because I feel like people,
some people might still
be very comfortable
in saying what this
participant said, for instance.
And I also wanted to bring some attention
to what limitations we had in
these groups that we convened.
I think one of them is that participants
really learned about this study,
a lot of them, via activism networks.
And so, we could expect
that these could be people
who are just more likely to be engaged
or who have less challenges
with technology, for instance.
So we might have missed
a lot of the people
that we did wanna engage just by virtue
of how we recruited folks.
And so, some final thoughts that I wanna,
and this is my last slide,
and I'm moving towards the end of my talk,
and would be really interested
in engaging in conversation
with everyone that's in the room,
but one of the, I think, key things
that we as researchers,
and as policy makers, and as clinicians,
and wherever we're sitting,
I think we need to
think a little bit about
how a lot of the mental health discourse
is sometimes obliterating
some really important issues
related to poverty,
related to social determinants of health,
and related to issues that are
more systemic in our society
rather than at the individual level.
I think one challenge is
how to actually connect
those various levels, both conceptually,
so that our practices can be more guided
towards approaches that are informed
by these multiple determinants,
but also in terms of
what type of research,
where money is being invested,
where funding goes for
these types of things,
if we wanna ramp up services,
or do we want to expand
a social net so that people don't fall
through the cracks so much,
and that people actually
have an opportunity
to climb out of the poverty cycle
that a lot of participants talked about.
So this was conceptualized
by some authors,
by Helen Henson, for instance,
as pathologizing poverty.
But Joanna Moncrieff,
who's another author,
also conceptualized it
as medicalizing misery.
And a lot of it has happened
after welfare reform
in the United States, after 1996,
in that really one of the few pathways
towards more stable benefits
currently in the United States
is through a psychiatric
diagnosis or chronic pain.
And that has impacts.
And Helen's work shows that way beyond
having a disability,
but also the subjective
and impacts of having to
identify yourself as
someone who's disabled,
and also the stigma that
that brings for people
actually end up institutionalizing
ways of being in the world
and in forms of existence.
So it has the potential to create harm
way beyond some of the more directly
and easily anticipated
results of a kind of a welfare system
that is structured in this way,
that a lot of kind of the gate-keeping
happens through the medical system.
And I think this idea of
crisis as a golden opportunity,
that's also, I mean, that was
kind of just a direct quote
from one of the papers
that came out early on
in the pandemic.
I mean, it really makes you wonder.
I mean, the pandemic hasn't really been
a great equalizer at all.
If anything, it just
reveals even more clearly
the horrendous inequities,
both in health,
and the systemic racism is
something that came to the fore
very acutely in this time,
the oppression, poverty.
You know, lack of universal healthcare
in the richest country of the world
is something that, you
know, as a discussion
that I didn't see a lot of.
And so, was it really a golden opportunity
or have we missed it?
Is there still time?
Those are questions that
I continue to ask myself.
It really certainly was
not the great equalizer.
I don't know what we're gonna start seeing
now that the eviction
moratorium was lifted
and what the consequences
will be of rolling back
some of the supports
that were put in place
when the pandemic started,
and what are gonna be the consequences
of the economic crisis
coupled with a sudden loss
of the few supports that
people had access to
just to stay afloat.
And really, so I think that
kind of the takeaway message
here for us was that, you know,
there's a need to articulate
these equally important levels
of the issue.
So the direct experience of the individual
and how people were
suffering or struggling
is an incredibly important element,
but how are they weaved in and connected
with the more systemic
and societal levels,
and how can we actually
address those things
beyond just the individual.
And then I also think that
one of the successful elements
of this work was that it
really centered the voices
of people who had firsthand experiences
in every stage of research,
from planning, to executing,
to analyzing the data, and
to planning next steps.
And so, I continue to advocate
and be a firm believer that
we can only find solutions
for these complicated issues
if we center the voices
and the experiences
of those who are most affected by it.
And so, I think this is
a good time to wrap up.
I, again, am so thankful
for this invitation,
and I hope that we can
have a discussion together
and a conversation.
So thank you very much,
again, to Priya and Ty
for putting this together,
and to the Frankes for
supporting this work.
- Thank you so much, Anna, for sharing
these wonderful insights
from this project.
If I may, there is a question in the chat,
but if I may open up by asking
the first question myself.
I was curious about, you
mentioned that there were people
who felt, even though they were
quite economically disadvantaged,
they felt that they didn't deserve
the second check, right?
And I was curious as to what you gathered
about that kind of mental
frame those people carried.
Is that a frame where they felt themselves
that they were a burden on society?
Was it some kind of, is
this the way in which,
did it reflect, do you think,
how they viewed their social status,
as how they view it or
how society views them,
and that this is something
they have internalized?
So I was very curious about people
and their reactions to what would be seen
as entitlements, right,
social entitlements,
social safety net entitlements.
- Yeah, I really appreciate that question.
And I think it's something
that I myself am grappling with
how to understand that in
the moment when I heard it.
And it wasn't endorsed
only by one participant.
Two other participants in the same group
endorsed the same view.
And just to provide a
little bit of context there,
really, this was a focus
group about poverty.
And so, these were persons who really,
without the benefits, or
without the stimulus check,
and without other benefits
that impacted housing,
would find themselves
either without housing
and on the streets,
or completely just unable to survive.
And so, for me, and this is
an active interpretation,
because in the moment,
it was really difficult
to understand because it
was just a very fixed idea
that just receiving,
and the idea was really articulated
as receiving money from the
government is always bad.
And I think it was really a clash of ideas
about the American way of life
and ideas about what pulling
yourself by the bootstraps
look like, and all of these kind of tropes
of independence and of freedom
that actually clash very directly
with some direct needs
that people might have,
or ways in which the government-
- That reality, right?
- That reality.
- The reality
of their lives, right?
- Yeah, but it is interesting
that you would stick with the tropes
and with the myths rather
than with reality itself.
And then, you know, this would be
an interesting topic of just more inquiry,
just to understand how
these things interact.
- And I think that one of
the reasons I picked that up
from what you were saying is,
you know, the rhetoric
with the right wing camp, if you will,
is that, and the fiscally conservative
members of, citizens of the country,
is that somehow the sort of people
who are on welfare would
just chronically love
to be on welfare, and they wanna continue
to be on welfare, and they are
happy to exploit the state.
So I think this would be very, very useful
to counter that narrative, right?
That it's not sort of a
uniformly held position.
There is a sense of dignity
in which, as you said,
people want to hang onto these tropes
at the expense of their
own individual needs
at the time, right?
So that is sort of what I found
really sort of intriguing about this.
And out of curiosity,
where they often people
who had dependents?
Were they single mothers who said this,
or were they single people,
or is it too hard to
classify a demographic
and say something?
- No, I mean, that is one participant
that I remember very well.
And this was a married man with
children and grandchildren.
And yeah, I mean, the other piece is that
that goes kind of in discourse,
kind of appeared side by side
with this idea of a cycle of poverty
that is impossible to get out of.
So it was interesting to see that,
this idea of people
loving being on benefits
doesn't really square out with the fact
that people are actually
struggling with benefits.
And even to come out of benefits,
it feels like a cycle that
is impossible to break.
And so, those contradictions,
I mean, those were really
interesting to see.
And I think that we saw them also
at the highest political
levels in this country,
and in my country in
Brazil certainly as well.
So, yeah, it's an interesting phenomena.
I hope that someone is looking into that,
cause I just don't have very good answers
to understand how that
thinking kind of evolves.
- Thank you so much.
So there's a question from Gerald Jordan,
who asked, "Great talk,
really interesting findings.
And it's amazing how you reached
beyond academic boundaries
to work with so many
different kinds of people.
What do you feel was
the most rewarding part
of doing this work?"
- Yeah, and I think this
is a great question.
I think that, yeah, when you
look at this entire project,
it seems that we did so
many different things
and I feel like that was really,
I think that what was rewarding
and what I really liked about it
is that we were able to kind of create
our path as we went along.
And so, I think a lot
of it was just building
from what we were listening
and then being able to identify
where we had to go next and then doing it.
So I think that this responsiveness
to kind of what we were
seeing in practice,
it's hardly ever possible
in the academic world,
where you have to plan everything ahead
and say what you're
gonna do and then do it.
So I think that this kind of
flipping of the order of things
and being able to just
have a very adaptive setup
was to me interesting.
And really, I just like
to work with people.
I think that the other rewarding piece
is just to have people
who are not academics
working with us in this group.
And I think it really pushes the work
closer to the ground and keeps things
more relevant, I think.
So I appreciate the question.
- And a wonderful talk.
Of course, we were expecting it to be
and it really delivered.
I wanted to know if you
could talk a bit more
about what you learned
about the human capacity
for resilience.
It's a double-edged
sword, as you pointed out,
because of course it comes
after great suffering.
The more resilient you are,
it's probably because you've
suffered that much more.
But what lessons might
you be able to derive,
as a psychologist, from people,
you know, from resiliency,
and how maybe aspects of resiliency
might be applied to people
who find themselves in extremely
difficult circumstances,
like health problems such as the pandemic.
- Yeah.
Thanks, Ty.
That's a thorny question. (laughs)
I'll respond the best way I can.
And it's actually funny that you asked
because resilience
became kind of a buzzword
that's even hard to kind
of define right now.
It's being used in so many ways.
I think a lot of it, my personal problem
with this concept is really how it places,
again, the emphasis on the individual.
And I think that that's
really why I always,
whenever I talk about
vulnerability and resilience,
I always do that with the caveat
that we really need to find better ways
to kind of conceptualize these ideas
and including more societal levels
and kind of environmental aspects.
And obviously, the individual
is always in the picture,
and we don't wanna be like,
we just don't wanna exclude
the individual either.
And for someone who's a
clinician, for instance,
who's, you know, before,
peer suffering, right?
If you're with a person and
that's what you're seeing,
that is the most important
thing in the moment.
So it's not to say that the individual
is not important, that
suffering doesn't exist.
But I think that the
field really struggles
with conceptual frameworks
that actually connect these
multiple levels of the issue.
And the ways in which we
conceptualize these things
really impact how we
think about treatment,
how we think about diagnosis,
how we think about public policy,
and how we put together
and how we set up systems of support,
and how we change societal structures.
And so, it's not a naive
question to ask,
what is the place of the individual,
what is the place of society
and where does suffering
factor into all of this?
It's actually a question
that I feel the field
has not done a good job at answering.
And then the pendulum swings
from one side to the other,
and that we really have a hard time
thinking about complex issues
in ways that we can actually
provide supports for people,
while also keeping in mind
the larger context in our work.
So that's kind of a long-winded,
a typical academic answer. (laughs)
A long wind winded response. (laughs)
- No, thank you though, thank you.
I mean, if I may follow up a bit,
you know, one of the things
that it seems a pitfall perhaps
of trying to understand
or derive some broader
benefit from resiliency
is that, could it lead to a
kind of insouciance, right?
So someone who has suffered greatly before
might then say, "Oh, well,
I've been through worse, right?
And not then take precautions.
I was wondering, with
the individuals you met,
did you see some of that,
and how you might have worked
with them if you did at all,
or you were just listening
to how they lived that dichotomy?
- Yeah, that did come up,
a lot actually.
Yes, you know, this, "Bring it on,"
you know, "I've seen worse."
And also, some people who said,
"I didn't care about exposure.
I didn't think that was a problem for me."
So that is the flip side of it.
Yeah, it can make you strong,
but it can also kind of devastate
your sense of self-worth,
your sense of self care,
your ability to care for yourself.
We heard a lot of that too.
And that is, I think, the flip side
of the whole resilience conversation
is that it can actually have dramatic
and devastating effects for people.
And even though they're there
and it seems like
they're powering through,
actually the experience
itself is just devastating.
And so, we did see that.
And in that way, this
is why whenever I say
we see immense resilience
and we see people are not as vulnerable
as we think they are, at the same time,
I'm always calling attention
to this caveat that we
shouldn't be romanticizing
extreme suffering.
I mean, it does prepare
people in certain ways
to endure more suffering,
but is that really what
we wanna accomplish
as a society, right?
It begs that question.
- So I had another question,
which is, we're really
sort of trying to assess
the role of mental health post pandemic.
Do you see there being a real shift
in the recognition and the
expansion of this category
of mental health,
and what counts as illness
and what counts as preventative measures,
has the pandemic,
disruptive as it has been,
has it fundamentally
shifted anything at all,
you think, in terms of how we view,
I mean, I don't think there is anybody
who survived the pandemic
without mental health consequences
of some sort or the other.
For most of us who are
fortunate, they were manageable,
but it goes without saying that it was
a period of extremes for all of us, right?
And has it really shifted
the conversation, Ana?
I mean, are we going to
see any lasting effects
of this once in a generation, I mean,
once in a hundred years sort of pandemic?
- That's a good question.
I mean, I don't know that
I can make any predictions
about-
- No, but just
your sense of it, your sense of-
- My feeling is that, so
one thing I feel did happen,
mental health is the most
talked-about subject.
I think that I cannot be in a space
where mental health is not a topic.
I feel like that's in the
news every single day,
and that this initial kind of prediction
of there will be a
tsunami of mental illness,
that which was said in the
beginning of the pandemic
was kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy,
in that by codifying and by understanding
the reactions that people were having
to this enormous disruption
as mental health problems,
I think that by placing it
in that conceptual field
created a lot of this situation.
Now, the way we're talking
about our suffering
and the way we're talking
about what happened to us
during this time is by saying
that we're having mental health problems.
And, you know, that is
true in so many ways.
I mean, this is the way that we're talking
about our experience.
We're not sleeping well, we have anxiety,
we haven't seen people in two years,
children haven't left the house in years
and interact with other kids.
So all of these things that
happen because of the pandemic,
obviously, are gonna have consequences
that we don't really anticipate,
we don't really know.
But the fact that the
conversation is so centered
in framing, this does concern me slightly
because it means that the response though,
how can we think of a response
outside of the individual treatment realm
and more related to, how can
we survive this as a society
and what kind of group
of people do we wanna be?
I feel like it kind of puts
that question to the side
when we focus so much
on individual suffering.
And I also think that for people
who are being diagnosed
with anxiety, depression,
or whatever diagnosis
we all might be getting,
how is that gonna help us,
and that's a sincere question,
how is that gonna help us make meaning
and find a way out of this
in a more collective way
rather than-
- Right, right.
I was gonna say, I mean,
I think the key word here
that you are bringing to
our attention repeatedly
is the collective
confrontation of these problems
rather than delegating
them to the individual.
I mean of course in America,
there's a very strong
self-help culture, right,
that predates the pandemic.
And I can only imagine that we are soon
going to be seeing lots and
lots of self-help books,
you know, get out of the pandemic funk,
help yourself get out
of the pandemic funk,
and so on and so forth, right?
So, yeah, I share your anxiety
that despite the scope of this pandemic,
it probably did not convert our society
from being so individualist
to a more communitarian,
collective vision sort of view.
And I think that it's sad
that if this didn't do it,
what else could really shift us to,
because I think, as you point out, right,
there's a way in which inequity
is sort of embedded in
this individualism, right?
So, I mean, I'm not gonna
get into the big questions
of capitalism, and hyper-capitalism,
and the difference between the individual
and the social models, east versus west.
I mean, there've been all these
sort of simplifying, north versus south.
People have done a lot of analysis, right,
trying to argue that there are
some inescapable consequences
of a capitalist and a
hyper-capitalist society.
But I think if any tsunami of an event
could have shifted the conversation,
shifted the perspective,
it was this pandemic.
I guess one can be optimistic
and say it's early days, but.
- Yeah.
- Are you an optimist about that? (laughs)
- I couldn't agree with you more, Priya.
I mean, I feel like I have to
be an optimist and hold hope,
but I'm also very uncertain.
Yeah, and I just wanted to acknowledge,
I didn't know that I could
see who the attendees are,
but wanted to acknowledge some people
who actually participated and
were part of our core group,
Larry Davidson, Claire Bien.
Gerald is here.
So I'm just happy that we have colleagues
in the room as well.
- Yeah, that's great.
And, yeah, hey, guys, feel
free to ask any questions.
I think Ty says she has one more.
So I feel bad that we
are monopolizing Ana.
So anyone else, and
it's getting on in time.
So before we wrap up, if
anyone else has any questions,
please type them up.
Meanwhile, Ty, go ahead.
You said you had one more question.
- Yeah, sure, thank you.
So you quoted, you offered some
really evocative quotations
from participants, but I
think the most poignant one,
in my opinion, was one about the person
who had suffered from
psychosis, a psychotic episode,
and that "I really needed,"
I'm misquoting now perhaps,
"but I really needed other people."
And, you know, he or she was isolated,
as the rest of us were
at some point, right,
especially early on.
And so, building on what
you were just discussing
before with Priya, you
probably don't wanna delve
into the realm of policy,
but what could it look like,
were there countries where it maybe,
or societies where this
didn't happen the same way,
where, you know, if people are suffering,
we're gregarious creatures
and we need one another,
and yet, we became, I guess,
perforce you to so atomize.
You know, really, I
mean, we weren't allowing
our children to play with other children.
And for a long time, we're
still really kind of in this
and just being so cautious,
and being, I guess, somehow,
viewing in the worst instances,
viewing one another as vectors of disease,
and kind of being so anxious
about reaching out to others.
And that, of course, has has
really deleterious effects
on an individual and a society.
Do you know of places
where that didn't happen
to that extent, and people were able
to kind of live a better model of it?
- I actually, so that is one,
and I'm curious to know
about that as well.
And I think we'll know more
once more research starts coming out.
But what comparing the
different responses, reactions,
the different social distancing measures,
the different shelter in place,
like, I think it'll take
time for us to understand
what the right choices were.
I will say that in
terms of our population,
the population of people
with psychiatric diagnosis,
as you saw, that is already clear
that they were disproportionately,
and died disproportionately
compared to the general population.
So that's something for us to consider,
that actually a psychiatric diagnosis,
a serious mental illness
does predict worse outcomes
for this.
And we also know that in
terms of access to services,
people who were receiving services,
and we had a lot of
people talk about this,
suddenly stopped receiving services,
or the services that
replaced the in-person,
the services that they got
were just not sufficient
to help them.
And so, I think there is,
you know, when I talk
about conceptualizing
and framing suffering in psychiatric terms
or in pathologizing poverty,
I wanna make sure that we
don't forget that people
are getting services and are
being helped by services,
and how access to
services actually suffered
with the pandemic.
And we saw that with other
health conditions as well,
that people just didn't
go for their checkups,
and didn't go for their screenings,
and how much of a broader
impact in general health
the whole pandemic had.
- Thank you.
- Sure.
- Let's see if there
are any more questions.
If not, we should, let
me just wait and see
if there's anything else
that's come up with the Q&A.
No, let's thank Ana for a wonderful talk
and a great project.
We wish you the best in continuing
with this very, very
important line of research.
And I also want to thank Ty, and Guy,
and Ryan today
for helping us with the AV,
and recording, and transcription services
throughout this academic year.
I want to thank you all
for coming to this talk
and for your support of all the events
that we have been holding this year.
So, bye, everyone.
Have a wonderful summer and
see you all back in the fall,
in person, where we hope to share
back to our tradition
of sharing lovely meals
and scholarship.
And, Barbara, I wanted to
say a special thank you
and bye to you, and hope
that we will see you in person in the fall
and have the joy of your company.
Ty, did you want to add anything?
- How could I build on that? (laughs)
- Oh, come on.
- (indistinct) of course,
but thank you so much, Ana.
I mean, I'm just struck by
how impactful your work is,
and how needed and necessary,
and so grateful that
we had the opportunity
to have you as a Franke fellow.
And thank you for what you're doing.
It's critical.
Thank you, Mrs. Franke.
- Thank you for that.
- Thank you, Priya.
- So here's giving you
a big round of applause
from all of us.
(everyone applauds)
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Okay, bye, everyone.
Bye and take care.
- Bye, everyone.
Yeah, bye-bye
- Bye-bye.